die Fahrt nach Butcher ist eine Reise in
die tiefsten Abgründe dieses Krieges am
Straßenrand Spuren der Kämpfe
die 20 Kilometer vor Kiew gelegene
Kleinstadt ist wegen der russischen
Massaker zum Sinnbild der Grausamkeit
dieses Krieges geworden
wir sind verabredet mit einem Mann der
alles miterlebt hat Basil Mulcher will
uns zeigen wie heftig damals in seiner
Straße gekämpft wurde
guten Tag
das ist ihr Haus
meine Webcam lief damals und machte
Aufnahmen aus diesem weißen Fenster ich
kann diese Aufnahmen gleich zeigen in
den ersten Tagen des Krieges waren hier
überall russische Soldaten
Sniper Boot tut der Scharfschütze war
hier und Sie können auf dem Bild sehen
und das war's die Kamera wurde
abgeschossen
das sind ihre letzten Aufnahmen
sie zeigen die ersten russischen Panzer
die Butcher erreichten
und dann war alles kaputt
das war ein Schock am Morgen war es noch
eine Straße und am Abend wie Berlin 1945
alles war zerstört hier gab es zwei
Häuser die wurden dem Erdboden
gleichgemacht
denn die ukrainischen Truppen hatten die
russischen Panzer bald aufgespürt und
nach heftigen Feuergefechten mit Drohne
zerstört
ich frage bei Silvers eher über die
Russen denkt
ich glaube das ist ein moderner
Faschismus
das ist russischer Faschismus die
Geschichte wiederholt sich immer wieder
und die nennen uns Nazis obwohl in
Wirklichkeit sie echte Nazis sind
[Musik]
doch es war noch nicht vorbei weitere
russische Truppen folgten der 66-Jährige
Ingenieur zeigte uns wo er sich mit
seiner Familie versteckte
[Musik]
Haus wird gerade repariert
treten Sie bitte ein vorsichtig hier ist
eine Baustelle ich habe ihr gesagt dass
wir uns hier verbarricadiert haben wir
sind hier nicht weggegangen und
versuchten nicht nach draußen zu gehen
damit uns niemand sieht
einmal erlebte vasilia eine Razzia der
Russen
und hier waren russische Soldaten
so standen sie hier
habt ihr Waffen im Haus gibt es hier
Soldaten nein keine die ganze Familie
das war unser Schutzraum während der
Schlacht saßen hier vier Personen und
darf hier Personen auf je zwei
Quadratmeter wir hatten nichts mehr wir
versteckten uns hier und hatten Angst
nach den Explosionen den Kämpfen kam die
absolute Stille
nach drei Wochen gelangweilt die Flucht
seine Familie überlebte viele seiner
Nachbarn nicht
zwar Häuserblocks weiter empfängt uns
Priester Andrea bin er führt uns in
seine Kirche eine Fotoausstellung
erinnert hier an die kreuetaten
458 Menschen starben in Butcher die
meisten erschossen oder schlagen manche
mit gefesselten Armen
[Musik]
als wir kamen sahen wir schon die ersten
Leichen und weiter dort auch noch eine
Leiche und noch eine in einer Straße 40
Menschen
[Musik]
der Priester begleitetes auf die Wiese
hinter seiner Kirche ein besonderer Ort
auf dieser Fläche gab es ein Massengrab
insgesamt wurden hier 116 Menschen
begraben darunter 30 Frauen und zwei
Kinder die beiden versuchten zusammen
mit der Familie die Stadt zu verlassen
aber ihr Auto wurde von einem
Panzerwagen von den Russen beschossen
die Mutter ist gestorben die zwei Kinder
sind gestorben sie verbrannten im Auto
die Gnadenlosigkeit viele russischer
Soldaten macht Pfarrer André heute noch
fassungslos
und unter dieser Besatzung erschossen
die Russen einfach Menschen sie
veranstalteten hier eine Art von Safari
wir tragen sie die Emotionen
sie dürfen
das einzige worüber ich nicht sprechen
möchte ist der Schmerz
sie müssen verstehen das ist schwierig
wenn man über die Emotionen spricht
bricht alles in einem zusammen
eine kleine Gedenkstätte erinnert an die
ermordeten wir haben keine Wahl sagt uns
der Priester zum Abschied die Ukraine
müssen Siegen auch für die vielen Opfer
von Butcher